the ultra 6633 is a
352 mile long race across the arctic
it's cold it didn't really get above -45
it's long i think that took me 150 hours
and most people
don't finish it
this is dave barrage he lives on the
isle of wight this is a small island off
the south coast of england
and last year
he won the ultra 6633
so i'm talking to him about what it
feels like
to race across the
arctic a typical marathon is 26.2 miles
long
so this is like 14 of them back to back
the distance is isolating you're on your
own for like two days at a time
and with negative 45 degree temperatures
it feels even longer
everything up there is big there's just
nothing to gauge distant spies nothing
to judge anything by you can see nothing
but white
so you start to think am i asleep or am
i dreaming this why am i actually moving
it's like being in a painting
it took dave six days to finish the race
and he only slept
a total of 10 hours
it's that exhaustion he says
that causes you to lose your mind
your mind just starts imagining all
sorts i went through
an avenue of trees and i thought i was
going through a disco party and every
time i approached somebody
they stopped talking and just looked at
me
but you can't stop
you've got to keep moving you think what
on earth is that coming towards me and
you know within two minutes you're
shivering you shouldn't have stopped
to look at something that's not there
i achieved what i wanted to achieve and
i finished it and i'm very grateful and
very lucky to have finished it of all
the races i've done it's one of the most
mentally challenging races out there and
it's probably the race that commands the
most respect anybody who finishes that
will while i would certainly
they've got my admiration